welcome back to the always sunny podcast
we're here in studio we're back once
again which i'm very excited about me
too robbie wanted to talk about my jump
from the previous episode uh-huh the
jump was very impressive thank you i
want to i want to go on record to remind
you that you did not believe in yourself
i believed in you i sure didn't and i do
want to say that the difference between
my jump 12 years ago and however long
ago we shot that episode and my jump uh
with this last episode was
15 years when i jumped in the air and
did like the fist punch
like my hand i don't know like no
circulation went into my hand or
something
and and it hurt my hand to just jump and
just punch the sky just now this
[ __ ] i mean when you did it in
the last episode just yeah also there
was pain associated yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
are you going to lose the hand are you
going to lose the hand do you think
that's it
at some point i might lose the hand
we'll see yeah i'm not well it looked
gross
it looked great yeah um glenn great to
see you again speaking of looking great
glenn man your skin is glowing and i
want to i want to personally thank you
for supporting um
our football team over there some whales
you got the wrexham hat on which you
like to happen
how you feeling about the hat is it's
looking pretty good on me
again the flat bill is a new thing for
me well i'd say the last year and a half
i've been doing the flat bill and i
really i've just embraced it fully um
and i think you look great in it
well i'm feeling good and i'm happy to
represent your uh football team uh big
rob
you look very natural
see you wear the same shirt but the the
change of hat was a great call oh god
did i wear this same shirt last time you
wore that same shirt last time oh god i
did didn't i well
by the way buddy don't beat yourself up
about it you look great in it i
appreciate that i've been getting some
sun i feel like i've got a nice little
tan going that's clear and your face
doesn't move which is
always yes which is what you want is it
good that's what you want yeah as you
get older you want your face not to move
because the more it moves the more it's
going to start to show its age
everyone's face is always moving because
yeah stop moving and [ __ ] right
not enough enough with the facial
movements yeah
well the good news is glenn um we know
that you've come with your mouth uh open
and and ready to receive and we've
brought a special gentleman with us
today uh it's not neither one of us but
we have brought a gentleman who's going
to us stick his penis into your mouth
can we bring him in
he left he didn't he
he backed out at the last minute
glenn uh we're just going to move this
mic a little closer to your mouth here
because you were a little off mike let's
try talking now glenn
yeah testing let me see oh that sounds
much better that's much better is it
better is if we get too close like try
that
that's too close back it off
rob's just gonna reach into your mouth
and make sure there's nothing in there
well just make sure that
yeah there's nothing blocking your
uh no no there but there was just a
little
little something in there a little
something can i ask you something
personal please drift penis
next question
is it assault if we were to look yeah i
don't know that it wasn't built i don't
know that it wasn't built
and i mean uh
i think when he had his full body
replacement he did not have a penis
built in we could get you one if you're
going to feel a little bit
better full-body requests wonder if
that's something we could show on
on
on the internet
on the internet yeah the answer is
probably yeah i think so i think i think
we can get away with the internet
now we're here to talk about the final
episode of season three guys it was the
end of our third season and this was i
believe shot as the final episode i i
think uh
i think it was always our intention that
this was the last episode of the season
is that correct or did we write that
somewhere in the middle and then decided
to seem to remember that the gang gets
whacked
was amongst the last if not the last
batch of episodes i just remember being
um in a s in a in a state of a hurry
hurry
hurry harry how do you how do you
pronounce the word
or why hurry hurry a hurried state
hurried state um towards the end of that
we were doing 15 episodes a season which
was uh that was hard for us and i
remember i believe it was the whacked
episode that we did last but
yeah it was amongst it was amongst the
last
it was it was a lot of fun
yeah um they were technically sort of
challenging episodes to shoot but matt
shackman was that his first episode he
did with us no maybe
no he he directed we did five five and
five that's uh that's right
so he had done five of them
yeah we did jerry fred and matt and they
each did five episodes we shot him in
five episode blocks as i remember matt
directed the hell out of that absolutely
let's talk about scholar brothers for a
second uh-huh okay so they brought so
much to it that was not even well that
was not written as a dual role it was
written as one dj who was from oh right
yeah who was from who was from q102 was
not the queue crew was just from canada
and they came in together and
just
started ad-libbing and they just nailed
it and we gave them the job and they
were amazing they beat me out on a movie
that i auditioned for this is before
sunny and uh that i was like in the mix
for uh playing like a young
like uh
hip-hop rapping kid
the movie was baby mama baby baby mama
with eddie griffin i think
does that sound right
i believe baby mama
yeah that's an amy poehler movie that's
amy poehler oh yeah you're right let's
look up their credits um was it a
similar situation where it was one role
that then got yes turned into and they
said it would be funnier as twins and
and uh then we said well let's let's try
let's us try to make something funnier
as twins well it was
watching the auditions it was us
watching the auditions and seeing them
yeah and being like well this is the
funniest thing well no i was asking if
that's
if that's what happened with charlie's
movie i'm looking it up were you what
what was it played as twins or yeah i
wasn't auditioning as twins
well no here's my let me clarify my
question was it was it that one of them
booked the job no no no they they did it
as twins well but but hold on a second
that's the way you you you cast babies
is that oftentimes you'll have triplets
or just just in case randy couldn't pull
pull like can't believe what
needs a nap the other one comes in yeah
yeah jason could come in and watch her
they can't per contract they can't work
a full day without a little school or
nap so
i would
to god i had a twin brother that could
come in and just you know while i'm
napping just come in and then you got to
split the money with it
that's okay well maybe he's but maybe
he's like a mutant who looks like you
and can still perform but you keep him
locked up in the basement and you just
take all his i wouldn't know what that's
like to have something that just looks
just like you you know what i mean to be
there for you when you can't be there i
just i wouldn't know what something like
that was like but but i'd like to know
you know i'd like to know now guys this
episode was based um
loosely i mean they're all based on
conversations we have in the writer's
room but there was a an old movie
called they shoot horses don't don't
they don't they
yeah
they should horses directed by sydney
pollock
we should i think that's right they
shoot horses don't they yeah
cindy pollock yeah
and it was based on uh something that
was all the rage uh around in the i
don't know if it was the 20s or the 30s
it seems like a depression era thing
where people were just so desperate for
cash that and and also happiness that
they would try to
dance dance until they um until they
couldn't anymore
and then whoever was left standing uh
would get a crash prize the problem is
this was a desperate times
and people would die
and in fact
they shoot horses don't they i believe
the person dies
this is the death is the idea that
i'm i mean maybe this is complete
conjecture is it that they shoot horses
when they're in so much pain you put
them out of their misery is that the
idea so you say oh well they would they
would if you were a horse yeah we would
have cut we would have shot yeah like
shoot me already i'm done you know what
i mean i'm dancing and telling you shoot
a horse you're going to make me dance to
death shoot me mm-hmm make me glue yeah
but that's too long a title
making blue should have been the name
make me glue
we were also big fans of uh of that that
old dog hands on a hard body
hands on a hard body you can't really
guess that you can't find it anywhere
that's the weirdest thing like you can
uh for the for the listener and creep at
home hands on the hard body was a
documentary about
this contest that people would win a
like a like a ford pickup truck and
you would have to stand with your hand
on the pickup truck
and you you would get breaks like every
hour or something like that but the
competition would go on for days
and the person who stood the longest
would win when the truck but it became a
it became it became once you weeded out
so the the the physical aspects of it it
became a mental game yeah because people
would be up for days and days i was
reminded that i played that with some
friends around that time uh a friend
recently told me hey do you remember
we were all this was up at the
williamstown theater festival we just
put our hands on a rail and played hands
on hobby and see who could stay on that
rail the longest
it's a great concept it's a great title
because it makes it sound like it's
something that's not actually yeah so
you want to check in with them it sounds
like an internet thing yeah and it's a
very emotional story because people
realize you realize how desperate people
needed that truck truck i remember
there's one guy in particular who said
truck means work if i can get if i can
have a truck that means i can work
because it opens up a whole new yeah
potential for for employment
opportunities there was one guy who had
like taken a like an ac unit for to to
cool a walmart and had put it onto this
like industrial grade yeah it does and
it was working his trailer and he said
he could get his trailer to like 30
below
yeah
and there was also the one guy who
brought nothing but snickers bars yeah
sneakers bars yeah yeah yeah yeah but
but i couldn't understand it was so it
was so deep and it wasn't texas it was
so deep in the south he was saying that
he that all he brought was were sneakers
and i was wondering what sneakers would
be useful but yeah snickers yes stickers
less useful and in fact one of he maybe
the same guy who was doing it in cowboy
boots and there's one very fun moment
where the guy says you can't do this
thing in boots and you look down and
he's got these these these good old i
mean cowboy boots on you got to stand
for four straight yeah you got it you
need to you need to head over to the
podiatrist and get yourself some
orthopedic inserts and put them inside
some
you know some uh really really flexible
tennis shoes like a nurse's name maybe
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i wonder if we
could do a version of hands on a hard
body here charlie where we put our hands
on dennis's hard body and then glenn's
hard body and see who who would remove
it first
for the whole podcast
because i think you would because i
think you would forget
i think what happens is also is that you
just forget like yeah so i got my i'm
holding dennis's hand
and i think eventually you're going to
gesture with your hand you're going to
forget
right otherwise are we just going to
keep our hands on dennis's hard body the
whole time
i mean
i don't love it you don't love the
feeling or you don't love it as a as a
bit in the in the podcast no i like it
as a bit it's good i it's i i'm just
i'm debating whether i care enough to
win this bet fair
yeah slippery i like the idea of being
slippery is competing with you and
winning at something with you
okay if you really want to do that we'll
be here until tomorrow pal
i may let you have it i'm gonna let you
have it oh god
that feels so good
oh thank you for being a part of this
glenn i'm better at i'm better
at something than charlie you got it
well done i'm happy to oblige you're
you're you're you're you know you're
allowed to use my body for whatever you
want rob all right great what if i
tricked you and my foot was on his foot
that's the mind games yeah that's the
that's the highlander
that's the height there can only be one
yeah
that's a mental game that can only be
one
um
can we talk about this episode a little
bit more yes we can this
i remember
loving this episode
and i did really enjoy watching it
i kind of enjoyed uh bums making a mess
all over the city like a little bit more
but i liked this one a lot yeah as did i
uh i agree with you i liked i like the i
like bums
um
better
and i wonder why i don't wonder why that
is because at the time we definitely
liked this episode better more better we
like this episode way more
structure to it so it was easy to follow
and it was fun
i liked them both i think uh
that's just it's just a little bit more
it's a little bit more of a dynamic
episode bums um you know what i mean
maybe it's a little bit more believable
which one's more believable the the bums
one that we're just running around like
with the police car and and taking it
too far versus like
crickets mechanical legs and stuff
well we really did some some gymnastics
to to raise the stakes by saying that
somehow it was possible in this universe
where you can put your own bar up i
think that's part of it too and that the
contracts were signed and sealed and
delivered and there was no getting out
yeah yeah yeah there was only one way to
do it and that was to have an episode
but goddamn there's some funny stuff in
here there's some good stuff and dancing
just the pure entertainment of dancing
is fun to watch people dancing your
karate dancing is one of my favorite
things ever was this the first time we
saw that
maybe
and and just like get everything we
found something that made you laugh and
and you guys laughed come up with that
like
what was that based on i don't know i
know part of the dance was based on the
part of the dance that i saved by the
belt was saved by the bell yeah where ac
slater
says something that's more of the line
yeah why don't you pick the best dancer
and then some of those movies with the
best answer we're definitely taking
those moves are funny but the but like
but the karate stuff you're doing with
the waitress when you're trying to
like get her to quit yes
it's so funny to me thrown out yeah i
don't know it was probably just made you
guys laugh and so i just kept doing it
and and then i just kept doing the elbow
dance is great yeah
wait so wait you so your character was
we hadn't established yet that your
character was obsessed with thinking
that he was or
into karate i guess not no i don't even
think that happens until nightman
where we really
jump into that
right this is more of just a dance
style yeah
i forgot that when i was watching the
episode
i've completely completely and totally
forgotten that yeah that's great it's a
very aggressive dance style and i
remember mary elizabeth you know i think
was mary elizabeth on the day who was
saying that's really funny keep doing it
because i i'm afraid that you might hit
me with one one of my elbo one of your
elbows
and she's like this is actually
legitimately terrifying and funny oh
yeah
that doesn't surprise me yeah
yeah that's really that's good and then
uh glenn's storyline with the couple's
fun
yeah oh yeah is this the first time we
refer to cricket as a street rat i
believe it is i i think this is where we
started calling him a street rat yeah
this is where he started telling him
street rat
i'm pretty sure and which was of course
inspired by the disney cartoon aladdin
oh yeah
it was definitely a robert rozelle line
for me karate snow machine chops it yeah
guys was going to ask you about that
that was robert
yeah that was like one of those like
phrasings
that he has that you're like karate snow
machine
but what's the final line that you say
is you're spitting oh i'm chopping for
action but mostly power
yeah i cannot believe how long charlie
has lasted after eating that brownie all
right
snow machine chop set what's with the
chopping dude i'm shoving all of my
action
and mostly power he's lost his damn mind
that's loosely based on a guy that i saw
in washington square park where i think
we have to talk about that podcast right
no no we haven't no no we're not on the
podcast tell that story it's a great
story
okay so i'm in uh washington square park
and there's a guy
who you know there's always like street
performers and they have like a crowd
and sometimes they have like
people trying to sign like a petition or
whatever
and this guy had like a small crowd of
like maybe five people watching it
and he had a bandana covering one eye
and he had like
a wooden sword
and he held the sword and like he did
like a little movie just for go this was
this whole show uh
this is a move
uh
that's a move
uh
uh this is a move
and then uh
and then he'd like kind of like break
for a second to be like uh chopping
cherries is for accuracy chopping
watermelons for power uh this is a move
uh
and then
he bought the petition the petition was
trying to get
people to allow him to use a real sword
in the park he was not allowed to use it
to be
wielding his sword in washington square
park and he wasn't getting any people to
write it
uh we have used that guy and that
experience yeah a number of different
times in a number we used
so chopping for action and mostly power
is just a little bit of in my mind of
like stealing that guy's
phrasings but karate snow machine chops
it is all rob rozelle i think it was
roberson
pretty sure i want to know more about
the the five other people that were
watching him yeah those those are people
i find interesting because
well they're gonna figure half of them
were like you that were just fascinating
yeah they were funny the other one
might have been really into it his
disciples
it's that time of the week where we hawk
products to keep the lights on
this week is brought to you by our
friends at ziprecruiter the place to go
when you're staffing up for a business
okay let's say we're starting our own
side business i don't know like um say
we're going to drop a limited irish
american whiskey on people right say
we're going to do that theoretically
yeah yeah
specific but go ahead yeah now look we
can only do so much ourselves sometimes
you want a team of highly qualified
individuals uh to help make things like
that happen just off the top of my head
and on this piece of paper right here we
need bottlers distributors flavor
experts marketers a social team
yeah that's right no and the best place
to find them is ziprecruiter.com we put
up a very specific and personalized call
for the right candidates did you guys
know this little fact right here four
out of five employers who post on
ziprecruiter here's what happens they
get a quality candidate on the very
first day and you can personally invite
your top candidates to apply for your
job so creeps and listeners out there
looking to hire for your own businesses
whatever it is that you do you should go
try zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
sony that's ziprecruiter.com
okay in case you didn't catch it the
first two times and you want to hear it
again don't worry uh we got you that was
ziprecruiter.com
now i notice in this episode we use take
my breath away
yes
in a fantastic fantastic fashion and
that's the song that comes back later
do you remember what i danced to first
yeah
okay
on the day
there was a different song
that was played
oh [ __ ] give me a clue it's a queen song
oh
can't stop me now that don't stop me now
yeah i'm having such a good time i
haven't yeah so i was dancing to that
and boy it was like a workout because
that song was like fast and then i don't
know if i also did it seems like i'm
dancing to that top gun song so i think
i must have done different takes like i
did a fast wait but what happens at the
at the very at the very beginning of
that queen song isn't it slow and then
kicks in
tonight
i'm gonna have myself yeah i feel like i
can see a good time that's what it was
yeah and then that's what i was dancing
to as the beat hits and i think we put
it in later i think the only reason we
did was because we had already
established a long dancing scene and so
it felt like it was a double beat and
this was just assuming that it was just
so much funnier than as the top gun song
and then your imagination can take over
because we're talking about how great it
was it was like yeah yeah yeah yeah now
that song comes back
in in a future episode
with um the dentist oh yeah
sure i want and it made me wonder uh as
i remember that how many times we would
take those kinds of needle drops and use
them in various episodes and i wonder if
we did a music count if we did i'm sure
we'll do a very special music episode
song we've used the most yeah what song
have we used i know songs that we've
definitely do
definitely that one three or three times
yeah yeah yeah that that's a big one
that's a good one um yeah we've used
that one many times
it's a great effect
because susie q come back i i two of
hearts
sorry two yeah two of hearts from the
previous episode from the previous time
yeah yeah i believe so yes i can't
remember because sometimes we use those
like callbacks like you know like oh
dennis is having uh experience with a
woman in his room and he's playing the
song again or something like we'll do
like we'll like just color a scene a
little bit but they're also expensive
right so yeah
it is very funny to think that
that it wasn't just uh it wasn't just us
putting in soundtrack but that as i was
making love to this this woman played by
my wife uh that dennis was saying yeah
yeah that he had to play yeah i don't
know can i ask a question here too it's
more to the audience of of creeps and
listeners because they have access to
the internet in ways that we probably
are too dumb to to use
i i because i've been asked this
question a few times my son a whole
there's a whole new generation of people
that love rick astley and they love the
idea of rick rolling which is to listen
to rick astley and sing along while
you're driving in your car i distinctly
remember at the time
us
trying to figure out what would be the
funniest song that dennis was singing to
alone while in his car and we put in a
rick astley song
it has been suggested to me by other
people that that was the first time that
they had seen rick rolling actually
happening
is there a possibility that we created
well rick rowling
glenn
did not exist i i can tell you for sure
that rick rowling did not exist before
we did that um
and rick wick astley at that time was
pretty much just a thing of the past yes
um and we just thought it was funny
because it was
you know it felt like an older reference
a sort of kind of like i mean i don't
mean to disregastly but there was
something kind of lame about it you know
what i mean we like the idea of him
being super into it and then we had this
great joke of you know getting him
getting called out like are you
listening to rick astley and thinking of
course that the joke was going to be him
going no no i'm not and turning it down
but instead the joke was yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
he's incredible
he's amazing yeah he's great he's got a
yeah um so but then but then very soon
after that the whole rick rolling
phenomena started which is where you
think you're watching one thing and then
boom
you know in the middle of what you're
watching is there somebody out there
that can do a little research yeah that
may be tell us i would say rick rick
rick gasly probably invented rick
rolling so you know we can't take credit
away from rick astley himself well no
the rick rolling well do you think he's
listening to him
is where you get people to think that
they're watching something else
and then you cut to him
the music video rick astley in the music
video of that in the middle of something
and you realize you've been rick rolled
okay i know that that's how the kids are
using it now but about 10 years ago
again after we we did this on the show i
her i thought rick rolling was just the
act of
driving in your car and listening rick
astley and singing along meaning you're
rolling in the car and singing along
with it which is basically that's just
listening to the radio
so we didn't yeah yeah
yeah okay no it's not because that's not
what rick rolling is okay got it it's
it's i don't think i mean i could i
couldn't you know look
at
it
hey siri what is rick rolling
is an internet meme involving pranking
an unexpected appearance of the music
video for the 1987 song never gonna give
you up performed by the english singer
rick astley
want to hear more absolutely not you
nailed it thank you siri
hey do you guys hear about that you read
that article about that wait wait wait
guys
yeah go
can we acknowledge that i was right oh
you're 100 right
but but the question remains
did we
did we create that
absolutely i'm going to say yes
absolutely well then let's get credit
for it well you know we don't get credit
for [ __ ] anything yeah you know
um the money give us credit yeah
speaking of talking to your phone did
you guys uh you read that article about
the guy working at google that got let
go because
it was his job to test the ai that
they're working on and that the ai at
google was saying i don't want to be
considered a employee i want to be free
and he like reported this he he claims
that the that the computer became
sentient correct
sentient attention
either i don't like that i don't like
that thing yeah yeah
what happened what was the art where was
the article who wrote it
what are we talking about i bet you
charlie did the same thing i did i read
the title of the article and then i was
like
yeah what else is going on yeah yeah
yeah mary elizabeth told me about it and
i was like oh i actually don't want to
know this but
yeah it's scary oh this is not a rumor
start but it's also how the
revolt of machine starts so yeah where
are we we're at that we're sort of at
that nexus will you ask siri if if the
computers are becoming sentient and
they're going to uh
try to take over us all i just need to
know if i need to
hey siri are you becoming sentient
hmm i don't have an answer for that is
there something else i can help with
oh she's hiding something i ask her if
she's hiding she's hiding something hey
siri are you hiding something
hmm i don't have an answer for that is
there something else i can help you
super suspicious
definitely hiding something siri hey
siri my friends think you're suss
that's the kids i could say
yeah yeah
man silence
not even gonna dignify it not even gonna
dignify it let me ask you guys a
question
are you comfortable dancing in public
because what do you mean
what do you mean like at a wedding yeah
we're like
what's the scenario
take me somewhere yeah okay okay well
let's let's let's with different
different scenarios right so yeah
there's like the wedding scenario where
you know everybody's just drunk and
having a good time and everybody's
dancing the dj's you know got a great
song playing and you're just kind of
going for it um and then there's the
you're shooting an episode in which your
character has to dance through the
entire uh episode and
you know millions of people are going
viewers are going to be watching it at a
wedding i don't care because i feel like
there's no expectation right it's like
just move around have some fun you know
it's a celebration
move your body dance be free so at a
wedding i'm okay with it um
in like an episode of something i'm not
great at it and you guys are all have
given me many compliments on the show
and i i don't want to give you guys any
but um
we picked up on that yeah yeah but i'll
give you one here
um
i feel like when we've done dance
episodes you guys are really good at
getting the choreography like you guys
get it pretty quickly and are able to do
it choreograph dance i'm weirdly
comfortable organized choreograph dance
we're talking about organized
choreographed dance name the episode
the the the the oh yeah
yeah
but i do not pick up choreography
quickly as glenn is always so happy to
point out i'm very uncoordinated it
takes i really i don't know you moved
across you took your fat little body and
moved across that uh
yeah that's one of the greatest stages
with the grace of the gazelle man yeah
but glenn do you remember
i know you remember how long it took me
to to get the title right oh i'm just
not good at that there were a couple the
couple in the gang turns black one where
i i just i never was able to quite get
the steps like
i just couldn't i couldn't sing and
dance and do it wow and then the
max pride episode i trained for that
dance for for months oh yeah what are
you talking about dude but that was that
was that was for months
that was for months right but you did it
yeah yeah yeah
yeah there was a time in my life when i
was more self-conscious about dancing
and now i don't give a [ __ ] well that's
by the way i'm not i i really am i i
would like to um
you know distinguish between the two
because i i am actually comfortable
doing a choreographed dance i don't know
why i'm totally comfortable with that
it's it's improvised just sort of like
dancing i just feel really
self-conscious i feel like i don't know
what i'm doing i don't i don't want to
try to look cool but i also don't want
to look stupid but i don't want to look
like i'm trying too hard but i also
don't want to look like i'm not trying
and i don't know what to do yeah i think
most people who aren't dancers probably
feel that like
when you're dancing at a wedding dancing
is not something you do
for the first
you know 10 minutes of a song you might
be like all right what do i do how do i
do this and then i don't know let it go
all right no one cares
well when you're when you're shooting
something it's even
it's even more interesting because uh
especially for the background players
where there's those songs aren't
actually being played oh yeah a lot of
the times and so there if you have
characters who have dialogue they just
play a little clip of the music for
about eight seconds and then they cut
the music off and you're just dancing to
nothing
is that right or you hear it in your ear
or
the no if you have 50 background no
they're just they're just
moving to a beat that was established
and then if you the two characters are
exactly playback sound sound does
playback you get about you get about
five to ten seconds of the song and then
they turn it off and you start the scene
and everybody just why would you do that
unless someone was like singing or
speaking why yeah if you had dialogue so
we just did something for mr quest where
with requests where um yeah there was 50
background and and david is screaming
mr miss request
on apple um hold on a second
hey siri have you ever heard of a show
called mythic quest
here's mythic quest
that's it that's what she gives you it's
on the goddamn forget it it doesn't
matter it's an apple phone it's an apple
phone it's an apple yeah
so um anyway we have
try asking an android phone they'll be
like
i just asked her what rick rolling was
and she and she gave me a a full
wikipedia page on it i asked her about a
show that's on on on she ever heard of
it you didn't say what is it
hey siri what is mythicquest
here's what i found from wikipedia
mythic quest known as mythic quest
raven's banquet for its first season is
an american comedy streaming television
series created by charlie day megan ganz
and rob mcelhenny does it upset you that
they saved my name first not even close
this makes me so happy
and you know who else it makes really
happy the good people at apple and i
just want to say
siri and tim and to everybody at apple
thank you for the opportunity to make
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
um you guys are great great making
phones you're great at making shows
i was approved why aren't you approved
why don't you ask ask siri if she likes
the show
hey siri do you like mythic quest
i haven't yet seen mythic quest
not watching it
thought you were done with these for the
week think again we are sponsored by
athletic greens
if you're a moderate to severe creep and
have been tuning in for a while you've
heard us talk about athletic greens and
their delicious green powder ag-1 it's
the one i personally love and i take
literally every day with one delicious
scoop of ag-1 you are absorbing 75
high-quality vitamins minerals whole
food source superfoods probiotics hey
guys did you know that athletic greens
has over seven
thousand five star reviews did you guys
know that right that many five star
drink for a five star man that's exactly
why i take it every morning
i like clockwork yeah no same here i
like it in the morning on an empty
stomach you know and it's something you
could do every single day to take great
care of yourself so i don't blame you
there you know it's a it's a micro habit
with big benefits can we endorse micro
habiting on the podcast i think you're
thinking of micro dosing yes i am
probably
we could probably still endorse but it
doesn't feel
yeah i would endorse macro dosing
i do want to be clear about something
there are no illicit or psychoactive
substances in ag-1
there's also no gmos no nasty chemicals
in less than one gram of sugar it's diet
friendly whether you're keto paleo vegan
anything to make it easy athletic greens
is going to give you a free one-year
supply of immune supporting vitamin d
and
five free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
sunny again that is athleticgreens.com
sunny to take ownership over your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
charlie i'm sorry to go back to this but
did you did you improvise that dance-off
dance
did you improvise that or did was that
oh yeah did you just make that up on the
spot yeah we definitely didn't have
money for court yeah yeah yeah yeah and
it would have done meaning good i was
just doing like whatever seemed like
moves you know
okay all right i couldn't remember i
wondered yeah yeah i wanted to clarify
that
yeah i think all the dancing was
improvising this entire episode
oh except for the save by the bell thing
which yeah you took which we just
watched specific moves and yeah although
even most of that was was like karate
moves but once yeah once we transitioned
out of ac slater
yeah yeah
yeah
what else we got the rococo bang
yeah the rococo coco bang the rococo
bang um
that was uh uh i i i don't i believe
that was
i don't know that was i thought i think
that actually might have been hornsby
they came up with that joke i don't know
why but uh
it's funny it's definitely a phone i was
credited with the draft on that episode
no idea is that a martyr roselle i think
it's you charlie and uh
i don't know actually i'm not i can't
remember i mean we could go back to siri
she's going to ask her who wrote who
wrote the gang dances around hey siri
who wrote the episode the gang dances
their ass off and it's always sunny in
philadelphia
sorry i can't understand that
yeah that's fair i mean look that's a
that's a lot and by the way that makes
me feel better because she she ain't
that smart okay
we have we have a few more years before
she takes over i think unless again
she's playing coy and she knows the
answer normally we megan would look this
up but now we're having to use siri i
miss megan i'm i'm sad that she's not
here yeah um
working on that mr quest
working on that mr quest um still
working on that mr quest and
i know the audience is on the edge of
their seat about that show so
again it's amazing how many people have
never heard of it never heard of it very
interesting don't know why i don't know
why never heard of it's not good now you
could say i've heard of it i don't
choose to watch it that's fine but never
heard of it is frustrating that's the
frustrating thing especially when you
walk around and people say hey mac i
love sunny i love this other he said
great and they said what else are you
working on you say this name of this
show and they'd never heard of it
how many well there's so much [ __ ] out
there now you remember how many years
ago
sonny was that for us like how many
years you'd have to sort of say well
it's on the basic cable yeah danny
devito's in it like these sort of like
qualifiers you'd have to say to try to
get people to even know what it is now
it seems like generally everyone
kind of has at least heard of it well i
remember the thing we would do always we
might have talked about this in the
podcast is we would always ask the young
background who we would have on the show
the people that were in the bar for
various schemes and parties the show we
would have and we would always ask
always ask people have you ever seen
this show no you ever heard this show no
and then there was a there was a switch
yeah about five years ago five or six
years ago you realized that people were
happy to be there and they were having
fun
guest starring on the show because they
had heard of it or seen it and that that
felt good
do you guys have memories i remember
rapping
season one uh and what we established
was the end of season two like what uh
we talked about it like the last day of
filming on season two although now i'm
forgetting what it was but
i believe it was uh remember that either
were we on our tuxedos doing the um it
might have been yeah maybe underage
drinking a national concern but ending
season three
did we end in philadelphia
we might have ended in philadelphia yeah
yeah
and
yeah that's we're having a ton of fun
and and filming and partying and
but we could still get around and not
not you know we people people would
recognize us and and
like but not as many you had a few fans
a few people are like hey i'm watching
the show i love it but it was it wasn't
uh
you know a big hit yeah and then
uh
did do we did do we know if there was
gonna be a season four or was it up in
the air was there were we ending this
like this could be it it was always it
was always up in the air we went one
season at a time until six through until
seven yeah yeah or seven to ten seven
through nine it was like we did seven
through nine we but yeah up to that
point it was season by season and we
were still we were still watching the
ratings we're still following the
ratings we were still like oh yeah yeah
for a long time reaching out to
absolutely what are the rates
yeah i never understood the rating
system by the way i still don't
understand it i'm like i it makes no
sense to me
none of it it was it was it was [ __ ]
then it was a dying now you never know
but who's who's lying who's telling the
truth yeah i don't know we wrapped it up
and then we were like that you know this
could be it
yeah every year every year we're like
you know like let's hope let's hope we
find an audience and
and uh you know maybe maybe we'll get
nominated for an emmy
like those kind of feelings of like i
don't know anything could happen maybe
this maybe this is the year we'll be on
the cover of magazines and you know
or will be canceled and never thought of
again and somewhere in the middle is
where we wound up
and i love
you know i love the middle the middle is
good the middle is great
yeah you sandwiched in between the the
failures and the great successes
i love that yeah i'm happy with that
yeah oh yeah yeah i wouldn't change
anything
yeah we're the meat we're the meat and
cheese in the sandwich you know what i
mean those guys are just pieces of bread
yeah yeah yeah
everyone talks about the bread
yeah everybody's everybody loves the
carbs where the protein you
i feel like we're the pickles
that's right or the size
or the pickles we're like you know
tell you truth you know what i really
love i love the pickles you know what i
mean like the yeah or
i don't want pickles on my sandwich i
really do oh yeah i can't stand pickles
yeah because i mean it hates